hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the second day of
the aim chess rapid Knockouts it is
Shakir mamidarov now with the white
pieces against Yang shisht of Duda with
black and after the last game you
probably thought okay we we saw the good
stuff of the match now obviously all the
other games will be a snooze Fest uh
well already in the second game is quite
the opposite so let's dive straight into
it mama has the white pieces and as you
can see D4 is already on the board but I
will just play it like this Pawn to D4
we have Ponta d5c for uh E6 Knight to F3
and now Knight to F6 so not Allah going
Knight to C3 to allow something like a
nimso Indian but Knight F3 Knight F6 and
now Knight the C3 so we get the second
best thing and that of course is daragos
in defense with Bishop to B4 Bishop to
G5 mommy Dr goes for the main line and
now D captures and C4 I did some work on
dargozin not so long ago so you can if
you if you try it online if you want to
you know try it it's a very nice defense
for example sometimes you can you can
try something like H6 here and then
those who haven't studied how to play
against the ragozen will sometimes move
the bishop back to H4 but this sort of
um a positional mistake because then you
you can just capture here the captures
and see four and after they try to
regain the pawn you can play B5 and
there's never a good way to actually win
back that pawn so once this H6 is played
you you kind of should capture on F6 but
as I've seen most players just don't
they play Bishop dh4 so if you want to
try it you know do try it you can get
some nice games from this but okay
Bishop G5 mommy there are dude of course
knows what's what here he plays D
captures on C4 right away Ponte E4 we
have Pawn to B5 and now challenging the
structure right away Ponte A4 we have
Pawn to C5 and now a captures on B5 we
have C captures on D4 all been played
before nothing new here the shop
captures and now G characters on F6 and
there is a game where this exact same
position was reached and it's even from
the Tata steel Masters tournament in
2014 between bodies of elephant and
Levon arunian where Queen capture Sun D4
was played but here Mom Jr plays Knight
captures on D4 he keeps the Queens on
the board and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game
and now how do you continue well you
should consider something like Rook to
G8 or Bishop to C5 those are the moves
or Bishop to B7 the move that Duda
played as it makes sense to put the
bishop on this diagonal now Bishop
captures on C4 by shock and now uh Queen
to B7 going after the bishop here the
problem with capturing this Pawn is uh
well even though the Knight is pinned
you can't really capture it I know you
guys are interested what about the pawn
so I'm just gonna show it the bishop
captures on e4 white will just castle
and it seems like everything is fine but
okay your Bishop is now hanging you have
to address this either by capturing or
by moving the bishop so okay you're not
gonna give up the bishop pair just like
that let's say queen B3 goes after the
bishop let's say you trade okay captures
captures uh now black will castle and
okay yeah it's a it's a nice possession
but not just that Black's position is
ruined here it's also uh winning by
force for example Rook fd1 goes after
the queen queen C8 and now Pawn to B6
and how are you going to deal with this
it's a it's a very nasty position that a
black really can't play if you if you
try to develop then you even allow some
ideas like Bishop to A6 attacking the
queen let's say captures captures and
once the queen moves you can even
Advance the pawn all the way to B7 so
that's why the E4 Pawn is not up for
grabs so here Queen to C7 attacking the
bishop and Mario goes Queen to B3
defense and attacks on B4 Bishop to C5
by Duda and now uh it's a it's again a
very interesting position where the
black king is still in the center of the
board Duda has developed the bishop pair
very nicely and now the engine says Rook
to D1 completely winning for a while but
it's such a disgusting line I'm not even
gonna bother you with that I'm just
going to show you what the momentaro
played because that's the uh the really
good stuff he played Knight captures on
E6 as you might have imagined F
characters Bishop captures on E6 and now
okay uh you've sacrificed some material
the black king is stuck in the middle of
the board uh how do you go after the
black we have knighted D7 by Duda and
mamidarov castles and now comes Rook the
d8 you could also consider Castle in
Queen side but it just looks really
really awful like The Rook controlling
the a file the other Rook coming to C1
the pawn here the Knight coming to D5
the bishop painting the Knight so it
just looks uh it just doesn't look like
something that you can do even though
the engine says no you can you can do
this it's not a problem but okay Rook
the d8 uh Shah decides to keep uh do the
decides to keep the uh King in the
center of the board and now Knight the
D5 attacking the queen here and even
though Bishop captures and D5 might be
something you would want to play you do
not want that Knight on D5 dude actually
keeps it there he plays uh Queen to E5
and now how do you continue how do you
put pressure on Black's position well
named plays the the cold-blooded King
the H1 it's just a wow move because so
many things are happening in front of
the black king do you bring this rock
into the game how do you bring this Rook
into the game to do attack no he just
plays King H1 and now F4 is coming you
don't really care if Queen ever captures
um on e4 uh because well that's that's
just not happening for example if Queen
captures you can even play Bishop
captures on D7 now if root captures
Knight captures here with a monster Fork
uh that doesn't really matter what you
played so I mean yeah you you're never
capturing this even if there was no Fork
you do not want to open up lines of
attack towards the black king so here uh
it's a very difficult position dude do
the place King the f8 but now he allows
mamidyar of uh the absolute uh winning
move and there's only one so uh be very
careful so uh try to find the only
winning idea in the position while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting uh well
just a spectacular move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course Queen to H3 there you have
it Queen to H3 with threats of Queen H6
check and also just picking up the
Knight there now the Knight is attacked
twice and look at this discovered by the
bishop discovered by the Knight Queen
will come to H6 that the black king will
not have anywhere to go so uh here how
do you defend well uh Duda tries Pawn to
F5 and it makes sense uh you you weaken
the Knight here if Pawn characters on F5
and also uh you disconnect the queen and
bishop's attack to the Knight on on D7
uh now comes Queen to H4 attacking The
Rook here and do the uh can't really
figure out a way out of this one so he
decides to go for Queen captures on E6
and it's definitely the way to go so
Queen captures an E6 sacrificing the
rook and d8 or rather just trading The
Exchange Wing captures with check King
to G7 and not mamidarov again playing
for the crowd Knight to F4 now offering
the queen for a nice Queen grab plus a
royal Fork because uh if the queen is
captured then this check comes with an
attack on The Rook You're Gonna Lose The
Rook as well king of six Knight captures
and of course the position is now uh
winning for for white even if you
capture opponent doesn't really matter
uh Shakira is up to pawns and he's up
the exchange so this is easily winning
for him so Queen to F7 instead now comes
Queen G5 check King to f8 and now e
captures an F5 Now setting up the D6
Square for the Knight Rook to G8
attacking the queen here and first queen
to H6 with check King to E8
and now Rook F to E1 starting the attack
against the black king bringing the
Rooks into the game King to d8 and now
okay you might be a bit worried about
this your knight can't move as long as
this is here so we just spawn to F3
Queen captures an F5 and now Rook ate
the C1 and now the black king is really
uh is really feeling unhappy on that d8
square Knight to f8 and now uh how do
you finish this game well there's always
that one move that we discuss and that
of course is Pawn to B4 a y Pawn to B4
well uh you have to see it to believe it
first mama you could play right away but
mamidara first prepares it nicely with
Pawn to B6 and now you see the problem
uh the queen has access to the to the B6
square and there's no way uh to actually
play this if you play Bishop captures
then you no longer control the D6 Square
then just Queen to D6 check and you get
the Checkmate it doesn't really matter
what you do if Queen the queen D7 Queen
F6 check Queen D7 and queen captures
will be Checkmate so you can't do this
so after B6 we have a capture Sun B6 and
now Pawn to B4 with the exact same idea
but now the bishop doesn't have uh a
square you can't really uh you can't go
to D6 uh you could go to E7 if you go to
E7 then Queen captures and B6 is a
possibility so uh you're not gonna have
fun there either so if you go let's say
Bishop TF2 then you uh again leave the
D6 when a square unguarded if you
capture on B4 then Queen captures and B6
comes again King to D7 and now Quinta uh
C7 will be Checkmate so not happening so
after B4 do the tries one last plan and
that is Rook captures and G2 but now uh
mommy darv can play pretty much anything
and he's still going to win this he just
captures the uh The Rook he doesn't
really care Queen captures an F3
threatening Checkmate but now a nice
Queen to D2 uh check and he was in this
position on move 31 that young shisht of
Duda behind the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you don't have to
worry about Checkmate anymore and once
the uh the the check threat has been
dealt with uh doesn't really matter how
I said Bishop D5 you're just gonna
collect the free Bishop here and you
don't really care you're up a full rook
and an exchange you have a rook for a
bishop and also a full Rook so
completely winning uh black has no
control play another absolute brilliance
by Shakira mamidarov who after losing
the first match now starts the second
match by winning the first two games and
he didn't just win them he absolutely
crushed it
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh really spectacular
stuff by mamajarov in this match hope we
hopefully see more uh I would like to
thank luxeminiabi and chakrapani Alan
cycle listerpan Joshua Baker and Derek
Alex Williams for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day